there's a cool place where you can watch
the playoff games right here in the
valley and maybe not spend so much money
yeah it is really cool a new pop-up
experience over at red rock resort
hector mejia you know he's already in
there good morning hector isn't it cool
it really is good morning guys yeah in
the last uh 20 minutes or so we took you
through
the giant golden eyes helmet we went
through the ice hallway now we're
showing you part of the inside
it's really cool and it's it gets even
better the entrance is complementary so
once you're here
you can order some drinks get some food
watch the game war if you're feeling
pretty fancy you can get some champagne
pop some champagne here and pick some up
from this vending machine or if you want
to have an outdoor experience
you're in luck because we have that too
the experience moves outdoors where you
can
you know just kick back watch the game
have some food
right next to a cool pool and joining us
live we have executive chef
lupe avila to talk to us about these
plates of deliciousness right in front
of us good morning sir good morning
welcome to red rock
thanks for having us so what did you
guys uh whip up for us this morning so
today we have some of the signature
dishes that we are presenting here at
crimson we have a
housemaid our house nachos that you have
the option of serving with chicken or
burning briskets uh are two renditions
of sliders one's a fried chicken slider
one's all beef angus
and then a chipotle glaze spare ribs
it all sounds and smells delicious so
let's move over to this table because
there are a lot of plates but
before we get to the rest of the plates
how do you guys sort of build a menu
to go along the lines of the vegas
golden knights you know we want to we
want to definitely
impress the guests with something that
has really good value
and everybody loves you know so the
sliders the burgers
uh a burnt end burrito just things that
people gravitate to
and the wings with the red peppers yeah
that's actually one of our signature
dishes at our noodle bar
and nobody wants to just eat a simple
you know chicken wing we had no
salt and pepper chicken wings you know
they're delicious
so lastly you know over the last week
you guys have been open for a week what
has the vibe been like
it's been amazing just the way that our
locals are embracing
you know the golden knights has created
an amazing ambiance here
awesome thank you for having us so
there's a lot more to talk about we'll
go back inside of the next half hour for
now reporting live hector mejia
eight news now back to you guys you're
getting closer and closer to that pool
he's ready if i fall i did not plan that
just remember
just remember swim first eat later
that's the rule